how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe now fortunately for
us a lot of things have been happening
and moving pretty quickly in regards to
the mcu the disney plus shows are well
on their way we got our first trailer
for the one division series not too long
ago
the falcon and the winter soldier is
currently filming and we are getting
many
many leaks for that series production
has resumed on many of the other marvel
projects and
we are getting more spider-man 3 news
than ever
including the reveal from a sony
executive that we are going to be
getting our first look
at spider-man 3 by the end of this year
so there's a ton of hype around
spider-man 3 right now but
with so many different reports coming
out each week people are finding it kind
of hard to keep up with everything going
on
so in this video i'm going to be going
over all of the characters that are
confirmed to be in spider-man 3 and all
of those that are rumored to be in
spider-man 3 as well
and if you love spider-man be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on all the spider-man news and
also so you have a chance to win an iron
spider funko pop
just subscribe like the video and leave
a comment down below well of course to
start it all off tom holland is coming
back as spider-man
now of course we obviously knew this but
he did give us quite a scare there when
the sony marvel deal was kind of up in
the air
but he is returning for spider-man 3
that will take place in the mcu and he's
bringing his friends with him
mj played by zendaya ned played by jacob
battle on and flash thompson played by
tony revolori are
returning for spider-man 3 and this is
confirmed and of course you have
probably heard the very recent and
exciting news that doctor strange is
going to be in spider-man 3.
this was confirmed a couple of weeks ago
and definitely brings a
whole entire aspect to what spider-man 3
could be for example when the morbius
trailer dropped we all saw that
spider-man existed within his universe
and then at the end of the trailer we
saw adrian tombs
aka vulture from spider-man far from
home
two different universes well doctor
strange is a character who does have the
ability to open up
portals to different universes meaning
that if somebody
say a villain found their way into our
main universe doctor strange would be
the one to know how to get them to go
back or defeat them
it is confirmed that doctor strange is
going to be taking on the mentor role of
peter parker
peter has basically had a mentor each
film in the first film he had tony stark
and the second one he
kind of had nick fury of course it was
actually talos
but he was there for him and of course
so was happy
and now the mentor in spider-man 3 will
be doctor strange
and speaking of doctor strange's role
and different universes it has been
confirmed that jamie foxx is going to be
reprising his role as
electro now of course we saw jamie foxx
playing elektro in the amazing
spider-man number two
and there's actually been kind of
conflicting rumors about his role
some reports have said that jamie foxx's
elektra was going to be an entirely
new electro and not from the amazing
spider-man universe
however when the announcement was made
that jamie foxx would be joining the
next spider-man film
as electro he posted to his instagram
confirming that he was indeed going to
be in the next film
and on the instagram post he put a
picture of spider-man
into the spider-verse now there's really
no reason for him to post a picture of
the spider-verse unless the spider-verse
actually
has something to do with his return and
also why would they have jaime fox play
electro again
if he was going to be a different
electro why not just get a different
actor
because after all that is kind of
confusing so as of right now it's not
yet confirmed which universe electro is
going to be from
but i'm going to assume that he is the
one from the amazing spider-man 2.
the next character is craven the hunter
who is presumed to be the main villain
of the movie
what we assume is going to happen since
peter parker's identity has been
revealed
everybody knows that he's spider-man
some people are going to want him dead
and that's where craven the hunter comes
in someone could have hired craven to
track down and take out
peter parker but recently there's
another rumor going around
of what craven the hunter could actually
be and i have to say
that if this rumor ends up being true i
am totally and completely okay with it
because i think it's awesome
but as rumor has it right now and theory
since it's not yet confirmed
craven the hunter could be an
inter-dimensional traveler who wants all
of the spider-man
dead this would actually be a really
cool twist since we're pretty sure
spider-man 3 is going to introduce the
spider-verse and of course the
multiverse and since we've had multiple
reports stating that andrew garfield
and toby maguire are reprising their
respective roles as spider-man
and will end up in the marvel cinematic
universe the same universe of course
which tom holland spider-man exists in
it would kind of make sense for kraven
the hunter going between different
universes
tracking down these different spider-man
but as of now treat that as a rumor
slash theory because there's nothing to
confirm it yet
but as i mentioned there have been
multiple reports stating that toby
maguire and andrew garfield are indeed
returning
and entering for the first time the
marvel cinematic universe
now if they are indeed going to be
returning the role that they're going to
play has yet to be revealed they could
end up playing a major role in
spider-man 3 or they could simply be
showing up for just a cameo but one
thing that does seem pretty certain
is that sony and marvel are trying to
set up a live
action spider-verse and with toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man
also comes the report that marvel
studios has already
cast miles morales for the mcu
at miles morelas for the mcu has been
cast it did not specifically save for
spider-man 3. but of course with
doctor strange being in spider-man 3
elektro probably coming from a different
universe and toby maguire and andrew
garfield also hopping universes
it would be really awesome if miles
morales could end up in this little
spider-verse as well
another character reportedly appearing
in spider-man 3 would be coming from a
different but also
known universe as well in fact it would
be the same universe as
electro the amazing spider-man 2s
universe and that character is
harry osborne reported by multiple
sources
osborne and ozcorp could be making their
way to the mcu
however these will reportedly be two
different things harry osborne will come
from the amazing spider-man 2's universe
but ozcorp will be set up in the mcu
by a norman osborne existing in the main
timeline
according to some reports and rumors the
avengers tower or what used to be the
avengers tower is going to be
an oscorp tower and we could be getting
norman osborn
now one last character that is
reportedly going to be in spider-man 3
is character dr spencer smythe now dr
smythe causes a lot of problems for
spidey in the comics and even worse he's
hired to cause all of these problems for
spidey by j
jonah jameson himself who is another
character confirmed to be in spider-man
3 who we also
saw in the post-credits scene of
spider-man far from home now of course
in true fashion j
jonah jameson thinks that spidey is a
menace and he gets dr
smythe to go after spider-man now dr
smythe himself doesn't really have any
powers however he does
create a group of robots that give
spidey a lot of problems and they're
called
the spider slayers so not only may we
see spider-man take on some pretty great
villains but he also may be taking on
some robots as well
and even if only half of these reports
end up being true spider-man 3 is going
to be
an amazing movie and hopefully debut and
set up
the spiderverse so out of all of these
characters who are reportedly going to
be in spider-man 3 let me know which one
you think is going to be the most fun to
see
and be sure to subscribe so you stay up
to date on all of the latest spider-man
3 news don't forget to give the video a
like and for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof